klutzy core expert Christophe Bauer
takes up in the mantra jet half a
century ago the sports car designed by
Frenchman rené Bonet caused a sensation
at the Salon de l'Automobile in Hawaii
with both its eccentric design and
innovative technology
Cristo says he's driving in 1966 jet
with a fiberglass body and a souped-up
1,300 cc four-cylinder engine it's
located right behind him under a bump in
the trunk this is a mid-engine vehicle
and he says that's what's really special
about the jet
the first viable mid-engine sports car
appeared in the 1930s auto unions Silver
Arrows carried their powerful engines
right behind the driver achieving ideal
weight distribution
the Cooper car company specialists
resurrected the mid-engine concept from
Formula three racing in the late 1940s
it's been the standard in Formula One
since the 1960s
this mantra jet also has the feel of a
racecar before the engines warmed up
christophe says it can be rather
stubborn knocking rattling and spitting
but once it's up to running temperature
upwards of 3,000 rpms
it shows what it's really made of then
it's a joy to step on the gas
it makes the dash from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour and eight seconds and
has a top speed of 210 surprising for a
little 1,300 cc engine Ultima bill van
de Beaune turned out the first 190 Jets
from 1962 to 1964 then arms manufacturer
mantra took control and changed various
details to ready the jet for larger
scale production jets continued to be
made until 1968 christophe says the
transmission is a disaster
finding the right gear as a matter of
pure luck not to mention the reverse
gear apparently the makers were saving
money by using the transmission of a
renault delivery van but they put it so
far and back that it's connected by a
tangle of rods with a little stick shift
so it's no fun at all for Christophe
about how mantra launched the most
potent version of its mid-engine rocket
in 1966 with a curb weight of 775 kilos
this jet puts out a good 105 horsepower
the street versions body design hardly
disguises its racecar origins
Kristoff's you a jet driver would have
to have an affinity for racing instead
of real car seats you lie in racing
bucket seats with your behind just above
the floor so it's nice and loud
the engine breeze down your neck when
there's no trace of noise insulation the
mantra seems oddly out of place like
some kind of spaceship against the
historical backdrop of Rivendell gardez
medieval belfry the story upon ollie
the streamlining of the fiberglass body
is interrupted only by the two air
scoops that who will be engine
the interior also reflects the racing
vibe a small steering wheel a short
gearshift and instruments everywhere
Krista thinks of Finnish sauna is
nothing compared to the mantra jet
he likes the flat windscreen but they
just make things hotter and the cooling
system is in front while the engine is
farther back and the hoses that connect
them run through the passenger
compartment the Finnish sauna feel is
rounded off by the hot engine mounted
behind the driver and insulated only by
this carpet the only thing to do is open
the roof but a sunroof was only
installed in 12 Jets this was because at
high speeds the wind could take out the
rear window just below the rear
windshield is the souped-up
four-cylinder engine developed by a me
day buddhini two dual carburetors
deliver high performance and Iran and
raspy sound the mantra jet was
originally conceived for the 24 Hours of
LeMans sports car races christophe
volume production was actually a kind of
byproduct clues are the custom-made
fiberglass body on a steel frame making
it very lightweight and the chassis with
formula three features also the
independent wishbone suspension and coil
springs
all this combined with a small steering
wheel allow the driver to take the
mantra in two curves with the greatest
of ease and precision
but the real novelty here is the
mid-engine before the jet only race cars
had ever placed the engine right by the
driver
it was mantra that brought this concept
out onto city streets
christos says only 1681 mantra jets were
ever built and it still made automotive
history as the first men engine car and
volume production and set a standard for
generations of super sports cars thanks
to the near-perfect weight distribution
52% in the back and 48% in front
it was absolutely unmatched in terms of
handling so it's without a doubt a
milestone in automotive history
it was also a trendsetter in the 1960s
ditomasso Lamborghini Lotus Ferrari
Porsche and almost every other
high-profile sports car maker brought
out a mid-engine car of their own